Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined today by Dr. Marianne Chalano, co-author of Something Happened in Our Town, a children's book about racial injustice from Magination Press, which is APA's Children's Books imprint. The story written with fellow psychologists and colleagues, Dr. Marrietta Collins and Dr. Anne-Han follows a white family and a black family as they discuss the police shooting of a black man in their town. The purpose of the book is to spark important discussions within families about racial injustice. Dr. Chalano is the director of Emory University's Parent-Chileged Interaction Therapy Program, as well as a professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天做客节目的嘉宾是玛丽安·查拉诺博士，她是《我们镇上发生的事》一书的合著者。这是一本关于种族不公正的儿童读物，由美国心理学会旗下的儿童图书出版机构Magination Press出版。这本书由查拉诺博士与心理学家同事玛丽埃塔·柯林斯博士和安妮·汉博士共同撰写，讲述了一个白人家庭和一个黑人家庭在讨论镇上发生的一起警察枪杀黑人事件。本书旨在激发家庭内部关于种族不公正的重要讨论。查拉诺博士是埃默里大学亲子互动治疗项目的主任，同时也是精神病学和行为科学教授。
Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Chilano. Thanks for inviting. So first I want to talk about what sparked your interest in this topic, you and your co-authors. I would say a couple of years ago, my co-authors and I became increasingly concerned about the disproportionate police shootings of unarmed African-American individuals, particularly boys and men. And we wondered how kids reacted to that. If kids heard about it, how they would react, what questions they would have. So we decided to write a book that would sort of be a platform for parents to discuss these events with their children and begin to discuss patterns of racial
感谢您今天参加我们的节目，查拉诺博士。谢谢您的邀请。首先，我想谈谈是什么激发了您和您的合著者对这个话题的兴趣。我想说，几年前，我和我的合著者们开始越来越关注警察对手无寸铁的非裔美国人，特别是男孩和男性的过度枪击事件。我们想知道孩子们对此有何反应。如果孩子们听说了这件事，他们会有什么反应，会有什么疑问。因此，我们决定写一本书，为家长们提供一个平台，与孩子讨论这些事件，并开始探讨我国种族偏见和不公正的模式。
bias and injustice in our country. So on the topic of that, I'm sure it's very tough for many parents to try to imagine telling their children about these complex issues, like race issues in America today. And many parents themselves may still be dealing with their own feelings about it and understanding what's going on within themselves. But why is it still important for parents to talk to their children? Well, I agree. It's a very complicated issue, and it's a very sensitive issue as well.
说到这个话题，我相信很多家长在试图向孩子讲述这些复杂问题（比如当今美国的种族问题）时，会感到非常困难。许多家长自己可能还在处理对此的感受，并试图理解内心深处发生了什么。但为什么家长与孩子谈论这些问题仍然很重要呢？嗯，我同意，这是一个非常复杂的问题，也是一个非常敏感的问题。
I think it's important for parents to talk about this issue because they're primarily responsible for socializing their children and raising them to live in the world. And kids observe the world, their social world. They observe who's included, who's excluded. They observe where people live. They observe racial disparities. They observe lots of things. They are consumers of media. They see how African Americans and whites are portrayed in the media.
我认为家长谈论这个问题很重要，因为他们主要负责孩子的社会化，并培养他们去适应这个世界。孩子们观察着这个世界，他们的社交世界。他们观察谁被包容，谁被排斥。他们观察人们住在哪里。他们观察种族差异。他们观察很多事情。他们是媒体的消费者。他们看到非裔美国人和白人在媒体中是如何被描绘的。
They observe things about their parents, who their parents' friends are, who their parents' close friends are, what their parents say, what their parents don't say verbally, but maybe say with their bodies. So they're picking up on a lot of messages about race and racial attitudes, who parents may inadvertently send out messages about who should be their friend and who should not be their friend. So they pick up on these things. And if we say nothing, then what's influencing our children's children's friends. racial attitudes are messages they get from the media, from their friends. But if you say things directly to the children about what you want them to learn, then it's
他们观察关于父母的事情，比如父母的朋友是谁，父母的密友是谁，父母说了什么，父母在言语上没说什么，但可能通过肢体语言表达了什么。所以他们接收到了很多关于种族和种族态度的信息，父母可能会无意中传递出关于谁应该成为朋友、谁不应该成为朋友的信息。所以他们会注意到这些。如果我们什么都不说，那么影响我们孩子种族态度的就是媒体和朋友。但如果你直接告诉孩子你希望他们学到什么，那么这更有可能奏效。
more likely to take. And particularly, children under the age of seven are very amenable to external instruction, to listening to their parents' words. As they get older, then experience ways in more on what they learn. But earlier, they really do listen to what we say. So what do we know about how kids learn about racism? Okay. Well, there's a field within psychology called.
特别是七岁以下的孩子，非常容易接受外部指导，听从父母的话。随着年龄增长，经验会在他们所学内容中占据更大比重。但在早期，他们确实会听我们说的话。那么，我们对孩子如何了解种族主义有什么了解呢？好的，心理学领域有一个分支叫做种族社会化。
called ethnic racial socialization, which has to do the verbal and nonverbal messages that parents tell their kids about the meaning and significance of race, racial identity, and how they should interact with people from another race. And what we know is that African American parents give these messages at a pretty early age. You know, they talk about what it means to be black in the United States, messages of cultural pride, messages, sometimes messages of mistrust, how you should act around white people, how to cope with racism, how to cope with racial injustice. We know less about what white parents do with white children in this area, but what we do know is that many white parents think race is not as relevant.
这与父母告诉孩子的关于种族、种族身份的意义和重要性，以及他们应该如何与不同种族的人互动时的言语和非言语信息有关。我们知道，非裔美国人父母在很小的时候就会传达这些信息。你知道，他们会谈论在美国作为黑人意味着什么，传达文化自豪感的信息，有时也会传达不信任的信息，比如在白人周围应该如何表现，如何应对种族主义，如何应对种族不公正。我们对白人父母在这一领域如何教育白人孩子了解较少，但我们确实知道，许多白人父母认为种族问题没那么重要。
So they don't talk about this. They don't have these conversations with their kids. And so that leaves the kids open to learning about race from other sources. And what's the biggest takeaway of this book for children and for parents? Well, we really want, number one, is we want parents and kids to talk about this. We want parents and kids to have discussions about what is racial bias, what is racial injustice, how important it is to treat everyone fairly. For the kids, there's basically two messages.
所以他们不谈论这个问题。他们不与孩子进行这些对话。这使得孩子们只能从其他来源了解种族问题。那么这本书对孩子和家长最大的启示是什么？嗯，我们最希望的第一点是，我们希望家长和孩子谈论这个问题。我们希望家长和孩子讨论什么是种族偏见，什么是种族不公正，公平对待每个人有多重要。对于孩子来说，基本上有两个信息。
One is we want to give them some actions they can take to counter acts of racial injustice, which for young children, often that's exclusion of peers. The other message we want to impart is diversity is something to be celebrated, not just tolerated, right? So there's value in diversity. The character, the older sister character of the white girl in the book says, you never know who's going to be your best friend. And that's a really important message.
一个是我们要给他们一些可以采取的行动来对抗种族不公正行为，对于年幼的孩子来说，这通常表现为排斥同龄人。我们要传达的另一个信息是，多样性是值得庆祝的，而不仅仅是被容忍，对吧？所以多样性是有价值的。书中白人女孩的姐姐角色说，你永远不知道谁会成为你最好的朋友。这是一个非常重要的信息。
So that you don't just include people because it's the right thing to do, but because there's value in including everybody. And one of the unique things about imagination press books is that they include information for parents, notes, sample questions, they can ask their children, which is a wonderful part of these books. So you explain the tips in the book and how they help parents and have these conversations and how they might spur in these dialogues? Well, sure, and we feel like that's a very important part of the book. So one of the things we've learned in doing some research is that, especially for white parents, I think 80% of
这样你不仅是因为这是正确的事情才包容他人，而是因为包容每个人是有价值的。Magination Press书籍的独特之处之一是它们包含了给家长的信息、笔记以及可以问孩子的问题样本，这是这些书非常棒的一部分。那么您能解释一下书中的建议，以及它们如何帮助家长进行这些对话，以及它们如何激发这些对话吗？当然，我们觉得这是书中非常重要的一部分。我们在做研究时学到的一件事是，特别是对于白人父母，我想80%的四到七岁孩子的白人父母想和孩子谈论种族问题，但他们真的不知道该怎么谈。
white parents of four to seven-year-old kids want to talk about race with their children, but they don't really know how. They don't know how to break it down into concepts that their young children can understand, and they're not even sure when is the right time to begin the conversation. And what usually happens is conversation begins when the child brings it to our attention,
他们不知道如何将其分解为年幼孩子能理解的概念，甚至不确定什么时候是开始对话的最佳时机。通常发生的情况是，当孩子引起我们注意时，对话就开始了。
when the child asks a question, often a potentially embarrassing question. And so the kid might say, how come Jada's skin is dirty? Or how come all the people in this neighborhood are black? Or something like that. And so it comes up when the child asks a question for many parents. And so we wanted to have sample questions and answers
当孩子问一个问题时，通常是一个可能令人尴尬的问题。所以孩子可能会问，为什么贾达的皮肤是脏的？或者为什么这个社区里的人都是黑人？或者类似的问题。所以当孩子问问题时，很多家长就会遇到这种情况。因此，我们想在书的结尾提供问题和答案样本作为资源。
as part of the resources at the end of the book. And also sample definitions and ways to answer the child's question in language that the kid can understand, and ways to translate concepts of inclusion into actions that children can take. And for African-American families or families of color, what advice do you have for them about how to talk to their children?
还有样本定义，以及用孩子能理解的语言回答孩子问题的方法，以及将包容性概念转化为孩子可以采取的行动的方法。对于非裔美国人家庭或有色人种家庭，您对他们如何与孩子交谈有什么建议？
Well, African-American families typically have these conversations earlier, and in particular, related to these police shootings of unarmed African-American individuals, many black parents talk about the conversation that they have to have with their children, about, especially their boys, about how to act in public, and how to not be a target, what actions they can take, how they can wear different clothes, how they can act, you know, when stopped by a police officer, to try to protect them. In terms of messages of cultural pride and history, I mean, there's an illustrated conversation
嗯，非裔美国人家庭通常更早进行这些对话，特别是关于警察枪杀手无寸铁的非裔美国人事件，许多黑人父母谈论他们必须与孩子（尤其是男孩）进行的对话，关于在公共场合如何表现，如何不成为目标，他们可以采取什么行动，如何穿不同的衣服，在被警察拦下时如何表现，以试图保护他们。关于文化自豪感和历史的信息，书中有一个非裔美国男孩和他父母的对话插图。
in the book with the African-American boy and his parents. And his parents do mention that they're very proud of their cultural history, and they mention powerful leaders, civil rights leaders, and talk about the value of collective action in addressing social justice. So that's all part of the book, and it's an example in the book with that family as well. And what's interesting is that the release day
他的父母确实提到他们为自己的文化历史感到非常自豪，他们提到了有影响力的领袖、民权领袖，并谈到了集体行动在解决社会正义方面的价值。所以这些都是书的一部分，书中那个家庭的例子也体现了这一点。有趣的是，这本书的发布日期提前了。
of this book was moved up, to the shooting of Stefan Clark, who is an unarmed black man who was in his grandmother's backyard and he was shot by police. Can you describe and explain why the book was moved up and the insignificance of that? Yeah, my understanding is the book was moved up because of that incident, because APA, Imagination Press and the authors wanted the family to have the book as a resource and wanted to be responsive to the communities of this tragic shooting effect. And this is the first picture book you and your co-authors have written. So, and you've received
因为斯特凡·克拉克的枪击事件，他是一名手无寸铁的黑人男子，当时在祖母的后院，被警察枪杀。您能描述并解释一下为什么这本书提前发布以及它的重要性吗？是的，据我所知，这本书是因为那起事件而提前发布的，因为美国心理学会、Magination Press和作者们希望家庭能把这本书作为资源，并希望对这起悲剧性枪击事件影响的社区做出回应。这是您和您的合著者写的第一本绘本。所以，你们最近收到了积极的评价和媒体报道，最近是在《亚特兰大宪法报》上，埃默里大学就在那里。所以您能谈谈这对您和您的合著者来说是什么样的体验吗？我们对这本书得到的积极反响感到非常高兴，特别是来自孩子们的反响。我们也向一群群孩子，以及一群群家长和孩子朗读过这本书，我们对得到的反馈感到非常满意。孩子们很容易理解排斥他人是不公平的，所以他们领会了这个信息。有些孩子在学校通过反偏见课程或在社会研究课上学习过种族主义，当他们了解奴隶制、吉姆·克劳法、种族隔离等等时，他们就有了一个背景来理解它。
positive reviews and press coverage most recently or very recently in the Atlanta Journal Constitution, which is where Emory is located. So can you talk about what that's been like for you and your co-authors? We've been delighted with the positive response to the book, especially from children. We've read the book to groups of children as well, and groups of parents and children, and we've been very pleased with the responses that we've gotten. kids readily understand that it's not fair to exclude other people, so they get that message. Some kids have studied racism in school with an anti-biased curriculum or in social studies when they learn about slavery and Jim Crow laws and segregation and all that, and so they have a context to put it in.
其他孩子因为年龄较小还没有学过这些，但他们仍然明白公平对待每个人是很重要的。所以我们收到了对这本书相当积极的反馈。这本书并非没有争议。在《国会山报》上发表的一篇评论文章基本上说这本书是反警察的。您和您的合著者发表了一篇反驳文章，说作者误解了这本书。您能解释一下他为什么会认为这本书对警察有偏见，以及
Other kids have not yet studied that because they're younger, but they still understand that it's important to treat everyone the same and to be fair to everyone. So we've gotten a pretty positive response to the book. And the book has not been without some controversy. There was an op-ed in the Hill that was published that basically said the book was anti-police. And you and your co-authors had a rebuttal op-ed that said that the author misunderstood the book. Can you explain why he might have perceived the book to be seen as bias against police and
您是如何回应的吗？您能详细说明一下您的回应吗？我们并不认为这本书是反警察的。它确实以警察枪杀一名手无寸铁的非裔美国男性开始。所以我们在书的开头非常直接地这样写了。《我们镇上发生的事》。大人们以为孩子们不知道这件事，但孩子们知道，他们有疑问。
how you responded that? Can you elaborate more on your response to him? So we don't conceptualize the book as being anti-police. It does start with a police shooting of an unarmed African-American male. So we were very direct in starting the book that way. Something happened in our town. The grown-ups didn't think the kids knew about it, but the kids knew about it, and they had questions.
家长们在解释这一事件时非常直接，说明该男子手无寸铁，警察枪杀该男子是一个错误。白人家庭和黑人家庭都这样做了，我们将这一行为置于某种政治或种族背景下，即我国种族差异和种族不公正的模式。我们非常努力地指出这是一个错误。
And the parents are very direct in how they explain this event, that the man was unarmed and that it was a mistake that the police officer shot the man. And both the white family and the black family, and we put that act into sort of political or racial context, the pattern of racial disparities and racial injustice in our country. We take great pains to point out that it was a mistake
并且许多警察，无论是黑人还是白人，都做出了正确的选择。但正如书中的角色之一，我相信是乔什的父亲，那位非裔美国父亲所说，我们不能总是指望他们做出正确的选择，这是一个沉重的信息。但我们觉得这是一个真实的信息。所以我们把它包含在里面了。我们认识到孩子们确实倾向于认为警察是值得信赖的守门人。
and that many cops, both black and white, make the right choice. But as one of the characters, I believe that Josh's father, the African-American father, in the story says, we can't always count on them to make the right choice, which is a hard message. But we felt it was a really message. And so we included that in there. We recognize that children do tend to think of police
他们通常是学校的保安等等。我们确实希望孩子们信任警察。但我们希望孩子们在成长过程中，能以更细致的方式理解他们的世界。事情不仅仅是好或坏，警察是好的，但有时他们会犯错。我们在教导孩子关于性虐待预防和个人身体安全时也采取这种态度。你知道，这确实会给孩子带来一些不适。在得知成年人可能会伤害他们后，他们可能不会信任某些成年人。
officers as trusted gatekeepers. They're often security guards at their schools and things like that. And we do want children to trust police officers. But we hope that children as they develop, they develop more nuanced ways of understanding their world. Things are not just good or bad, right? and police officers are good, but sometimes they make mistakes. We also adopt this attitude when we're teaching children about sex abuse prevention and about personal body safety. You know, it does create some discomfort in children. They may not trust some adults after they learn that adults could hurt them.
但我们觉得，为了孩子的个人安全，这种不适是我们谈论这些话题时必须接受的。因此，我们也认为，为了社会正义的结果，值得我们去承受谈论某些警察做出错误选择时所感到的暂时不适。那么，家长或监护人是否担心他们的孩子读了这本书后会害怕警察，尤其是年幼的孩子，比如四五岁的孩子？你知道，害怕警察这一点，除了他们可能已经因为听说警察枪杀手无寸铁的非裔美国人而产生的恐惧之外，并没有出现太多。
But we feel like the outcome of personal safety for the child is worth that discomfort that we have to embrace when we talk about that with them. with them. So we also feel that the outcome of social justice is worth the temporary discomfort we feel when we have to talk about how some police officers make the wrong choice. And is there any worry for parents or caregivers that their children might read this book and be scared of the police, especially young children, I mean the four or five-year-old age range? You know, that scared of the police, that has not come up as much other than fear that they may already
我有一些孩子对警察杀了一个他们不该杀的人感到惊讶。他们对那个错误感到惊讶。但我没有收到人们感到害怕的反应。那么，根据这些反应，读者、孩子、家庭和监护人的反应如何？他们和您以及您的合著者交流过吗？
have based on hearing about police shootings of unarmed African American individuals. I've had some kids be surprised that the police officer killed someone who they didn't, they shouldn't have killed. And they surprised at that mistake. But I haven't had reactions of people that were scared. And so going off of the reaction, what has the reaction been from, you know, from readers and from children and from families, caregivers? What have they told you and with you and your co-authors?
这取决于你问谁，对吧？所以家长们，许多家长称这本书大胆或雄心勃勃，特别是非裔美国人父母告诉我，他们很感激这本书现在可以提供给他们。我们也听到了白人父母的反馈，他们告诉我们这本书对他们也非常重要，他们一直想尝试与孩子谈论种族问题，但不知道具体该怎么做。所以他们发现，特别是书后的建议非常有帮助。那么这本书的目标年龄段是多少？
So it sort of depends on who you ask, right? So parents, many parents have called the book bold or ambitious, and particularly African-American parents have told me that they're grateful that this book is now available to them. We've also heard from white parents who've told us that this book is very important to them as well, that they have been meaning to try to have a conversation about race with their children, but they didn't know exactly how to address it. And so they have found, particularly the tips in the back, very helpful as well. So what age range is this book targeted for?
它的目标群体是四到八岁的孩子，但我们真的觉得家长应该决定他们认为孩子什么时候准备好读这本书。家长应该先读一遍，看看后面的建议。我们觉得家长最了解自己的孩子，有些家长可能会选择在孩子四岁时给他们读这本书。其他家长可能会说，我的孩子还没准备好。七岁。一些八岁以上的孩子也可能从书中有所收获。我们觉得四岁以下的孩子可能无法理解书中的大部分内容。非常感谢您参加我们的节目，查拉诺博士。谢谢邀请我。
So it's targeted for kids four to eight, but we really feel like parents should make the decision about when they think their child is ready for this book. And parents should read it first and look at the tips in the back. We feel like parents know their kids best and may, some parents may choose to read this book to their child and they're four. other parents may say, my child's not ready yet. Seven. And some kids that are older than eight may get something out of the book as well. We feel that kids younger than four probably wouldn't understand a lot of the book. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Chalano. Thanks for having me.
有关《我们镇上发生的事》的更多信息并订购该书，请访问美国心理学会网站。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，例如《美国心理学会期刊对话》（关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究）和《进度记录》（讨论心理学实践）。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的美国心理学会播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看关于我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是凯特琳·卢纳，来自美国心理学会。
For more information about something happened in our town and to order the book, please visit APA's website. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts such as the APA Journal's Dialogue, about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes which discusses the practice of psychology you can find all of our APA podcasts on iTunes Stitcher or wherever you get your podcast you can also go to our website at speaking of psychology.org and listen to more episodes and see more resources about the topics we discuss I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological
本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Association There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.